county schools likely will not return to
learning in person anytime
soon last night trustees were briefed on
the district's coronavirus response
back in july the board set some strict
requirements for reopening schools
that includes a 5 percent or lower
positivity rate
and a downward trend in cases for 14
days
well a doctor with the southern nevada
health district last night said clark
county is not close to those benchmarks
but he would support the board's
decision to return if they have a plan
for limiting capacity and social
distancing
board members though made it clear
there's no easy answer
would it be more safe for everybody to
keep schools
closed or at least only
partially open um i don't know i just
feel really uncomfortable with this
whole thing
and it doesn't seem like there's a lot
of answers and i really don't like the
answer of
just reopen because it's not going to
get better this year
the school board plans to vote on the
future of in-person learning on november
12th we will of course follow that for
you